invité pour conclure cette édition
catherine piller bonsoir vous êtes seule
la directrice de l'hôpital pédiatrique
de bullion également présidente de
l'association constance une association
créée afin de récolter des fonds pour
construire une maison des parents un
lieu pour héberger les familles les
proches des jeunes patients pour éviter
l' isolement jusqu'à aujourd'hui une
telle maison existait sur le site de
bullion elle a dû fermer pour des
raisons de conformité le monde de normes
de sécurité d'évolution de ces questions
au fil du temps et donc aujourd'hui il
nous reste à peu près huit ans mais qui
que l'on installé attention temporaire
véritablement solution temporaire nous
et donc la création de cette association
pour récolter des fonds jusqu'à un
million d'euros nécessaire pour ouvrir
une vingtaine de deux lieux d'accueil
pour ces familles alors une vingtaine de
lieux d'accueil d'hébergement privilégié
et intime pour privilégier la relation
avec la famille l'enfant spécialisé sur
place et puis aussi des lieux communs
des lieux de vie commun une salle à
manger bien légitimement une cuisine
enfin bon tout ce qui permettra en même
temps le loisir qui est un aussi
important à développer
donc là on a eu la chance quand même
d'avoir récolté 100 mille euros des
pièces jaunes
cent mille euros de la fondation
princesse grace de monaco et l'institut
national du cancer qui nous a donné 329
1000 euros donc aujourd'hui vous pouvez
déjà débuté des travaux
il me manque de ces normes en cours pour
l'instant c'est un peu court il me
faudra encore deux cent mille euros ce
qui me permettrait déjà de pouvoir
installer une quinzaine de lieux
d'hébergement
parce qu'on s'oriente sur du
développement durable en modulaire avec
façade en bois pour que ce soit
parfaitement conforme à cette belle
région des yvelines serre dans la forêt
l'hôpital étant dans la forêt il y
aurait tout une harmonie puis en même
temps donner un petit peu l'idée aux
parents que il passe dans un lieu un peu
privilégié un peu maison de vacances si
vous voulez tout en ayant leurs enfants
à proximité et avec les celliers
aujourd'hui sont véritablement
indispensable au delà même de la
thérapie que vous pouvez prodiguer les
soins que vous apportez à ces différents
enfants que vous accueillez il faut
aussi ce lieu pour qu'ils puissent se
retrouver avec leurs familles et que les
familles suivent aussi l'être
traitement qu'ils sont alors c'est
indispensable déjà pour une raison c'est
que l'hôpital de bullion reçoit les
enfants pour des maladies rares des
cancers ont fait les chimiothérapies à
bullion et vous imaginez que cela se
fait sur des délais assez longs
on ne peut pas avoir de rupture de au
sens des liens qui lient à entre les
parents et les enfants
et donc c'est une manière de les
regrouper de les retrouver alors que
l'enfant peut être en état un peu de
faiblesse ou autre par ailleurs on vient
d'ouvrir une maison d'éducation
thérapeutique quand on a des maladies
rares par exemple malheureusement ce une
maladie que les enfants subissent avis
est donc le but c'est aussi d'apprendre
à l'enfant et aux parents une prise en
charge qui permet un retour à domicile
qui va se faire plus rapidement et au
quotidien et on a mis en place un
système de télémédecine qui fera qu'on
sera à distance en lien avec les parents
les enfants d'ailleurs des familles qui
parfois viennent de très loin par
exemple on reçoit les grands brûlés qui
viennent un peu de monde entier qui sont
pris en charge être son on est très très
spécialisés en france sur ces questions
et bien on apprendre à l'enfant et aux
parents la prise en charge a posteriori
de la brûlure et puis il pourra repartir
chez lui donc encore une fois d'où
l'utilité de cette maison des familles
elle est essentielle ces lieux qui sont
véritablement indispensable et un petit
vidéo clip pour sensibiliser et inciter
les gens justement à donner on peut
d'ailleurs déjà d'ores et déjà le
préciser les dons sont déductibles des
impôts
si vous faites un don pour cette
association constancin pour l'hôpital
bullion c'est important vous nous disiez
il ya un petit peu un challenge soirée
vous manque à peu près de 100000 euros
on espère que les téléspectateurs
pourront contribuer et vous aider à
ouvrir en tout cas ses premiers
logements alors je le disais un petit
vidéo clip a été réalisé
il sera diffusé sur plusieurs chaînes de
la tnt le voici aujourd'hui camille à 7
ans et sa famille ne peut pas être à ses
côtés
les hospitalisations peuvent être
longues et les distances séparant les
enfants de leur famille très grande
allant même parfois au delà de nos
frontières aidez nous à réaliser la
maison des familles pour que les enfants
puissent se retrouver avec leurs proches
voilà pour ce clip et on a reconnu la
voix de daniel auteuil d'ailleurs qu'ils
partagent c'est un moment extraordinaire
je les appelais vraiment il était en
plein tournage
il m'a rappelé immédiatement sans savoir
qui j'étais
j'ai posé le sujet en trois secondes m'a
dit oui tout de suite après demain
rendez-vous dans le studio est vraiment
avec une humanité extraordinaire il a il
a donné sa voix pour ce clip est
vraiment c'était un très très beau
moment
alors on peut imaginer compte tenu du
nombre de téléspectateurs que vous avez
si chacun donne un euro
en allant sur le site ww pour un assaut
constance point fr comment je vois sur
le clip ça y est on vous invite tous à
venir couper les rubans avons bien sûr
pour la transpiration viendront voir
comment évolue ce dossier on espère que
nous les saint quentinois les yvelinois
vont contribuer à l'ouverture est donc
de ces logements pour les familles
aujourd'hui comme la situation est
temporaire n'est que quelques chants
tels que le logement c'est véritablement
difficile aujourd'hui pour pour les
familles les situations que vous
rencontrez parce qu'il faut expliquer à
ces familles aujourd'hui à l'heure
actuelle qu'elles ne peuvent pas rester
avec leurs enfants elles peuvent rester
de manière très temporaire parce que les
quelques chambres qui nous restent sont
dans un pavillon où les enfants sont
hospitalisés en particulier où nous
avons tout l'oncologie et je pense qu'il
est essentiel même si c'est sur le site
de l'hôpital de leur donner un moment de
répit pour se retrouver avec leurs
enfants sans être toujours dans le blog
de l'hôpital et au milieu des soins
alors la chance que nous avons à bullion
s'éteint dans un contexte assez
exceptionnel au milieu de la forêt si un
jour vous nous fait le plaisir de venir
vous verrez des enfants passaient en
jogging avec un sac à dos et au début
vous êtes un peu étonné vous demandant
si vous êtes véritablement dans un
hôpital
sauf que la sonde se trouve dans le sac
à dos et on fait vraiment le maximum
pour que l'enfant est une vie normale et
par ailleurs pour important à côté du
site où nous voulons construire cette
maison des familles nous avons une école
primaire
et une école secondaire un collège donc
on fait les soins peuvent se faire très
tôt le matin
et puis l'enfant va suivre son cours de
mathématiques après puis d'éducation
thérapeutique et il retrouve papa et
maman dans la maison des familles
comment aider toutes ces familles
justement qui rencontrent des
difficultés avec des enfants qui sont
hospitalisés juste pour conclure nous
allons écouter ce rapide micro-trottoir
que nous avons réalisé avec cette
question plein de choses déjà en fait
débloquer des fonds pour pouvoir les
accompagner en fait tous les jours
financer en fait toutes les aides les
soins les fauteuils roulants tout ça en
fait pour pouvoir en fait aider ces
familles là il faut déjà avoir des
renseignements bien bien ferme pour bar
pour l'accompagnement on n'est jamais
assez renseigné leur permettent au moins
de les suivants l'hôpital de vivre avec
l'hôpital s'ils sont à l'hôpital
aso voilà assauts constance point fr je
voulais vous redonner ce site internet
c'est le site internet où il faut vous
rendre pour tout savoir sur
l'association et de l'hôpital
pédiatrique du lion qui accueillent ces
enfants et surtout qui souhaiteraient
accueillir les familles pour pouvoir les
encadrer merci encore d'être venu nous
parler de cette initiative vous le
verrez prochainement sur vos écrans de
télévision sur la tnt le petit clip avec
et daniel auteuil qui a qui s'est prêté
au jeu
vous nous l'avez dit assez spontanément
c'est la fin de cette édition du 7 8 je
vous retrouve lundi pour le direct à 18h
mais n'oubliez pas ce week end
catherine mulato pour l'édition du
week-end forcément le point complet sur
tout ce qui s'est passé sur les yvelines
depuis lundi